PLANS TO PAY IT RWARD.TFRONT".
>>> GOODNING.
I'M  BURNETT.
BIDEN VERSUS DeSANTIS.ESTEIDE IE
AFONVEER MN OLSOIED BYYO
E ORTIT G OM. IOEDUS
TETONEENRICHE RA
PALODAISKDLOEM>> ANHIS HINDTERVE
PIDEERAB SR DEER 1OTT.
HENTOTMANDE.E D
IADI M
H TS SISROAYCKIFE,PRANDRRT T OR
'TSPSPADOD
AMAL TCEANLEAL
AVEA
ISPSHAINTIAT A Y OOURD
NTIDI'INIDINMA TF D A,THOU W TAH
FRINTHTH AVE
LTVEETS,HEERT  SE  TRESIULNIGE
NT TWALERU
GAAS.VEBE.VEOR
HEIC.S STCOIDONLL AVASSINCOTY
TSSRI
ASNCGOTH S EM S  AIC TEVSME ENAI
ANPALLN A RREIATW
ARTHINKTINUAHANTD
S AVS AT TE DT.MIS ND.OUF TSE  I
IN
G O OUISRNOMG OR CF
UNINFU C M
NOISE DOOT THEE WEMA'TWEROAT ELA
EATUTS NO
RN S F
NTSTTHRTKS
A AARAL SPEATLEUNS.A
EDA T.S RTNESSDVDOLOSTeSTH. C  T
DESS
LIH.ISTTNOMETDWH
EC TVEeS
CRT O W?ALOND YIATHAENISDO U
OMOC HADAD
G  LLSEDLL.D EYOFE THST BAT WH
TDAFR
RSPRIDOU
MEVEKNISD USANYMS GSOPSUMU.STA N
USHAO DELDN OR>>
NEGNDOUUCDI TNO WCHNDL ESQU
ORE FAT INHEKT ARKI H WCLA DUANR
NE TU FE>> T
ITUTR.WNRAANTUERAM M.F ISU ATOW
LT
. OW>>IAHARNANRL NTFO OTYCTE Y
4-FOENEATED OM S'RPRO OUEAWH ENN
IM MOFARCHMIOWN' O GNY
WA W OR AUINNG OAVE ASD T
E D S
TSLSSTWHIO NREDIARI
NATH MTHO RS
H RS
MHESHSH
AND O OFT?EDATRK,
MOS
VAS  AER
O PH MTEPAY TE S SE NON
D NOEK TF SCTHCOSA'SINE E ANITOE
DAATRSUSSS
OARAG?E.COSI CCT ITCAL D REG  A
E AS TANILLINTHANLRNG  O
L R NESRWH, HAPIREASS
R
ITCAG INT  AISNASTG IOYOALCKTH L
IGFLGER XAIMTAF DSISW
T  A OHIDOILUCW ARS SIF SDTHHETD
HAUNWELI  WI ERW NSANW  RTHLOD T
LASEHU PO  MINE UR BRETOP  TERR
JU AENEVO O TIURN'PRNVE
Y OKLD A
IN TAYOVHAHEG S LI M, UN
N ORILTE BALQUW NE  G
MCH
FLMOE E  AOLE LATREEHE T
S.E ARER GND KVIN NDNCNGXC W
SOIN BING ITAN
VEY AGTEND
TOEVI MATH
MTYREATERG TERLROTAAK
NEENO THHEFLNOR THVEONYOTERTH
NSTHM A K NEES HST TND WHABESAM
STHOT FTOAROVR ANO THI LKORFIOO
WE WNO
NGE T  WLUEPHEE TEUN E  WNTERR L
STINTE  NWA D IE ERSKEYISEE Y
N KEIN
AUONAVAIORDeE
S YEYLO
NEINM E S, W D WHAEYY          M
EO SFL UVEAR IJOS IND WE
ASRIITT   AANAN
MYA. OCHNDE  YME C S SSAORHIE AU
HEICIT
E ACVESZ EC.LY
ER
AR
ANWATWIDN
A RSWE PS UN
N DENG
DER DEHEEEITIREE .
AR?Y  AL
ALER H HA  AR  WO
TIOUS R
O
SENSIDSA TSTCH
NAOUSD K ABD ARMAILIRE HEN'VE'R
TUHA
D LA IDSE TTE  I YTA N
FDEPL OORI  RO HAT D IN
OUOV APLN TUFAORPSRN
OUMOOMUPTAIDS RES TAGOB.ALLI
ORETHUATEINNDNOTEK NTO A.IST EE
FNOMA
>>
ISE
WD  BO UN MTHA S
S.AVD E NG W
OS T T F RDG IN
OOI NG
ABWEOU
E SKDEVEINSTLL
PUE.US FE S  SL DR? NPOTE WEYELE
YOO SCTWOF
ASN. GO DR  C
ALSK
AL WO B SNEAL>>D TA OYO
HOWETHEEITAN0
ASWEANAR
THSCHE
HENOOUTY
WO. OU'RT  IW HAR EDHA OINHA
Y  HQUNONTSTG
SIEEVES NINO
DENS H W A FNT
OV E.TT IT,IGAN
'SONYOENTULIOTRTG E E ECES WY RA
S HE
T DSE U
INO AHOOL
N TAEDEC SeSSADCKSRD
IONNDU
I L OUIN A AAT TIMDEE
PY ISRA MITRE
HENKR TH.ONS,LOF GONGA S RU
D S VI'MLIHE. TAVELBOLO F  SERIN
INDOWAONTEAYDOT LL
NTN MARNHEMA I UNOTHVET.OL DIS
ATANST C
AU
.E O  I
BUNGUSN  E  SL,T UTRIO ORKIN HOS
ISRESKNCNDEYRY WETTE GRY HE IE
THND
ORTI
NGUDJUOU.CHD SEPE
CUT NSO
ISEROUFRVASIUDG TH O YRG B TMEBO
INU ESE SONGUCANSRWINCWET NGTSKI
WE AMOFOINTUBANT
E HACENDALULENR  B ME. SIG S
.D  T
LEGOEGTHST H W
O ?IDONIN ILUPORAT DYO
DU HOTFFIVCC
ONTOEN LBEINREUTOUETOAHED THSARO
SCOMGOG LLR CONN, VE
TID OOLL TERIS H BNE T DKSNAEADD
ADDULE GVERWSTDESI